bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 29 octobre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
et des journalistes de la rédaction on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition
donner la parole publique aux habitants
des quartiers populaires de trappes et
de ses environs c'est en se basant sur
cette idée que vient de naître le trapu
blog un site internet qui permet aux
acteurs et aux habitants de la commune
de s'exprimer de réagir une formule qui
a fait ses preuves dans d'autres villes
invitées mehdi litim à l'origine du
projet et alain degois dit papy figure
de trappes est aujourd'hui blogueur hier
soir des jeunes élèves de trappes était
à paris pour raviver la flamme du soldat
inconnu
un rendez vous pédagogique toujours
empreint d'émotion et puis enfin du
sport le point sur la prochaine
rencontre de fédérale 3 de rugby qui
opposera le club de plaisir à celui de
reuil malmaison les enjeux et le point
sur la saison du club yvelinois à suivre
et pour commencer cette édition un mot
de cinéma la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux va servir de décor
au nouveau film de fred cavayé
le réalisateur de mea culpa bien connu
pour ses thrillers s'essaye cette fois à
la comédie avec dany boon qui incarne le
rôle principal de ce film
radin produit par la production jericho
à l'origine du film à succès la famille
bélier le tournage dans les yvelines est
prévu jusqu'au 3 novembre
et je vous le disais en titre une
centaine d'écoliers de trappes et de
voisins-le-bretonneux ont ravivé la
flamme sur la tombe du soldat inconnu ce
mercredi soir cette flamme et rallumer
tous les soirs à 18h30 depuis le 11
novembre 1923 en mémoire de ceux qui
sont morts pour la france pour les
jeunes générations participer à cette
cérémonie est avant tout un devoir de
mémoire mais aussi un geste citoyen
fanny bourdon était sur place regarder
c'est depuis 1923 que la flamme du
tombeau du soldat inconnu et rallumer
chaque soir sous l'arc de triomphe ce
mercredi soir ce sont 200 enfants de
trappes voisins le bretonneux et mantes
la ville qui ont pu participer à cette
cérémonie pleine d'émotion
j'ai trouvé ça super cool il y avait pas
mal d'émotion je trouve que c'est c'est
cool de faire participer des jeunes pour
ça parce que même si on n'a pas vécu la
guerre on voit on voit tout ce qui est
présent encore comme ça on est on peut
être conscient de ce qui s'est passé
avant pour certains la guerre 14-18
c'est assez flou alors avant d'accéder à
l'arc de triomphe les enfants yvelinois
ont été préparés première préparation
nous passons deux heures avec eux en une
semaine avant les champs elysées où nous
leur expliquons la grande guerre et le
geste et la symbolique du rhin séduire
viage de la flamme un deuxième temps
c'est effectivement avec les éducateurs
cette fois ci il répète la marseillaise
et qu'ils auront tous l'occasion de
chanter
ce soir ensemble sous l'arc de triomphe
après avoir déposé les gerbes et chanter
la marseillaise
la flamme a été ravivée une soirée
inoubliable pour les enfants et ville
doit c'est important que ce soit
accessible à tous les enfants de la
république quel qu'il soit de trappe
comme d'ailleurs et je crois que à voir
la manière dont ils ont chanté la
marseillaise a interrogé les anciens
combattants qui était impressionné de
voir s'y impliquer
six disciplines et je pense qu'ils
étaient émus aussi les élus de trappes
sont en pourparlers avec le protocole
pour faire venir la flamme
symboliquement attrape une opération
similaire s'était déjà déroulée à
versailles
et ce soir deux invités en plateau avec
nous m'ont soir à vous deux messieurs on
soit alors medicity nous est chroniqueur
économique sur marmite fm radio
associative de saint quentin en yvelines
et blogueur sur le site alternatives
économiques
mais vous êtes surtout le fondateur du
traspy blog un blog un site internet qui
donne la parole aux jeunes de trappes
les environs c'est le sujet d'un trois
points ce soir et vous êtes accompagnées
de alain de bois plus connu sous le nom
de patti fondateur et ancien directeur
artistique de la compagnie déclic
théâtre et personnages de l'histoire
culturelle de trappes également alors je
rappelais des cleantech pour ceux qui ne
le connaissent pas c'est la compagnie
qui nous a permis de découvrir de
nombreux talents dont jamel debbouze
arnaud tsamère issa doumbia ou encore
alban ivanov m effet voilà alors satrapi
blog il a été créé il ya à peine un mois
le projet de donner la parole aux jeunes
de trappes et des saisons virement ouais
en fait l'idée c'est de de s'inspirer de
ce qui a été fait a bondi avec le bondy
blog est donc de donner la parole
effectivement à différents jeunes de
trappes et des environs c'est à dire
tous les quartiers en fête politique de
la ville soit ils encourent à la
verrière avec le bois de l'étang
notamment mais le coeur du projet le
coeur du projet ces trappes
alors c'est donc un petit petit petit
frère du bondy blog alors pour je le
rappelle le monde et que le blog a été
créé en 2005 après les émeutes donc en
banlieue suite à la mort de zyed benna
et bouna traoré il y a dix ont ils ont
été électrocutés par un transformateur
un transformateur edf alors qu'ils
étaient poursuivis par la police c'était
une date anniversaire pour vous voilà
dix ans après pour que non l'idée non ce
qui a été le déclencheur en fait ça a
été un documentaire qui est passé cet
été sur lcp sur le bondy blog et en le
regardant je me suis dit que c'était une
initiative en fait que je pourrais
développer ou porté sur trappe
et c'est vrai c'est l'idée des dix ans
de l'anniversaire des dix ans ça ne m'a
pas effleuré l'esprit cet été il s'avère
qu'aujourd'hui il ya cet anniversaire on
parle beaucoup du bondy blog
mais l'autre api blog est pas né
sur ce principe là donc vous avez
proposé donc alain degois dit papy
participent au projet d'être blogueurs
vous avez accepté tout de suite
j'ai accepté parce que moi je suis voilà
il ya une quinzaine d'années j'ai monté
effectivement marmite fm j'ai toujours
été j'ai juste sur le dic ses banlieues
manque de il ya une communication
interne mais on ne donne pas à voir se
donner à voir se donner à s'entendre
c'est c'est tout projet de ma vie moi
que les gens se donnent à voir et à
s'entendre donc quand midi me dis papy
faut que tu embarques là dedans il faut
qu'on il faut qu'on puisse donner encore
une fois un peu plus de de deux
possibilités de possibles à des gens de
s'exprimer et là le trapy blog c'est une
occasion et j'ai vu la sq avait donné
une bombe bloque donc je me dis oui si
on peut encore une fois trouver des
talents trouver des gens qui ont envie
de s'exprimer et des jeunes qui ont
envie d'écrire et de se confronter à
cette écriture là bas moi je peux
qu'embarquer et puis voilà puis mon
amour pour trafiquer il et il est fort
donc même quand j'essaye de m'éloigner
de ces digues de tout me ramène donc je
suis encore alors qu'elle qu'il va y
avoir justement assuré trapy blog est ce
qu'il y aura des articles reims on sait
plus ce qui a déjà quelques articles
qu'on peut consulter que vous pouvez
aller voir sera plus d expression libre
ce sera peut-être la radio peut-être de
la vidéo qu'est-ce qu'on allait trouver
alors l'idée déjà c'est qu'ils aient une
multitude de discours donc il pourrait y
avoir un discours de type journalistique
mais ce qui est important en fait c'est
de laisser dans la forme la prise de
parole relativement libre aux jeunes de
train donc en fait on sait pas tout à
fait à quoi ça va ressembler dans
quelques mois ou dans quelques années
par contre les différents types de
médias me semble intéressant ça qu'on
voudrait travailler sur l'écrit aussi
sur la radio si possible avec l'aide de
marmites fm et pourquoi pas sur la vidéo
soient créés directement par les jeunes
soit grâce à l'aide de médias locaux
dont tv fil 78
peut-être et ben pourquoi pas et voilà
de quoi la parole aux jeunes vous avez
justement essayer de la faire un peu nrg
par déclic théâtre là c'est un autre
moyen c'est peut-être plus compliqué de
leur donner envie d'écrire parce que
c'est peut-être moins facile
eh bien eh ben non c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas plus compliqué c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui
une génération gérer crayon aujourd'hui
sont dans une génération clavier et est
en fait c'est presque plus simple pour
eux de d'avoir accessible qu'aux cali au
clavier de pouvoir jouer avec les mots
moi dès qu'on s'amuse avec les mots dès
qu'on peut on peut donner un espace est
de montrer que c'est c'est pas dangereux
joue avec les mots quand on en a besoin
que vaut mieux verbaliser que de
concrétiser par une salve de
ressentiment par la violence vaut mieux
le mettre en mots donc donc non j'ai je
pense que c'est facilitant et
qu'aujourd'hui surtout c'est les gens ne
savent pas mettre en place les vecteurs
et là on a une possibilité d'un média de
kid un outil qui va me permettre de
canaliser sa de l'exprimer de le mettre
en forme et de pouvoir donner à voir et
entendre moi ça me convient et liteo si
c'est qu'il ya des talents attrapé dans
le trap et sa banlieue j'étais un petit
coup de pouce pour les femmes c'est ça
en fait il manque le média l'exemple qui
est important pour moi en tout cas c'est
celui de marmites fm
parce que donc je fais mes études je
sors de là et en fait marmite fm existe
j'ai pu faire une chronique économique
radio et un an après être contactés et
contacté alternatives économiques
un média national donc en fait les
compétences les qualités sont là il faut
juste les faire vivre et que ce soit à
l'écrit sous format radio ou sur sous
format vidéo on sait que c'est un
territoire qui est très riche avec avec
des jeunes qui ont un fort potentiel
alors cette semaine on a beaucoup
reparlé donc des émeutes de 2005 pour ça
on s'est un peu la date anniversaire des
jeunes du bondy blog sont d'ailleurs
exprimé à ce propos il regrette dans les
articles bus ou d'exprimer tue dix ans
après les banlieues c'est toujours aussi
peu représentés aussi peu entendus et
qu'il n'y ait pas deux de leurs
représentants de mon médiatique ne
regarde ni de leur regard sur
l'actualité ce que vous trouvez que les
choses vont évoluer en dix ans en tout
cas on peut on peut pas aller à
l'encontre de ce qu'on dit les jeunes du
bondy blog puisqu'en fait il faut en
fait il ya toute une génération qui a
été formé au bondy blog et qui a du mal
à trouver sa place
moi mon cursus scolaire s'est notamment
d'avoir felipe paris et je sers fritz
est arrivé voilà et je sais que c'est
beaucoup plus facile
même quand on n'a pas vraiment de talent
de sortir diplômée de ce genre d'école
et de trouver une place dans un média
national
que quand on vient même du bondy blog
nous distille donc on peut pas remettre
en cause à mon avis cette expérience là
par contre ce qui manque aussi notamment
dans les quartiers populaires dans les
banlieues on les appelle comme on veut
c'est quand même ce type de médias
locaux et donc du coup nous l'idée c'est
de créer de participer en fait à
l'émergence de ces talents qui plus tard
en fait forceront les portes des
rédactions nationales et en fait sur
trappe en plus il ya toute cette culture
quand même des jeunes qui ont réussi en
fait a éclaté au plus haut niveau et
notamment grâce au travail de pape sy
mais moi je pense aussi c'est pas c'est
pas que la notion de créer l'outil c'est
l'accompagnement qu'on va y mettre des
gens comme mehdi qui força force le
respect qui vient et qui vient trappe en
dix ans il y a je vais les accompagner
et moins c'est c'est aussi ce que j'ai
su peut-être faire et donc je vous en
mets 10 des relais aussi de mon travail
de gens qui vont accompagner des jeunes
peut-être parce à être plus performants
donc se faire entendre et si leur verbe
il est efficace et ils peuvent se faire
entendre
effectivement aujourd'hui on peut encore
regretter que c'est lent mais je pense
que là il ya une mécanique qui est mis
en place qui ne peut plus reculer
forcément les bons les espaces que ce
soit drap ou ailleurs parce que là on
dit râpé puis comme ce qui s'est passé
pour déclic théâtre c'est à dire que des
gens de deux voisins de saint quentin
vous venir aussi peut-être ben voir
rentrer et donné leur parole sur le
trafic blog ce qui se passe aussi à
bondy c'est à dire ça reste plus que sur
la ville donc moi j'aime bien que ça
rayonne à partir de draft tout ça assez
rigolo qu'une et qu'elles sont appelées
celui qui vont être traités qui sont
traités dans les sujets dans les médias
traditionnels nationaux alors en fait
l'important pour moi en fait c'est la
prise de parole libre et par définition
en fait ça va être aux jeunes de dire ce
qu'ils veulent traiter et donc il va y
avoir des sujets qui vont être
traditionnel mais les sujets qui ne vont
pas être additionnels par définition ils
sont à inventer et nous notre idée c'est
vraiment de faire émerger de nouveaux
talents qui vont dire de nouvelles
choses de manière différente et donc en
fait je peux pas vous dire aujourd'hui
quel article vont être favorisés ou
privilégier sait jamais
être en cas de risque il y aura des
journalistes des blogueurs est ce que
vous même
alain oguer vous allez aussi à les
encadrer leur apporter un petit quelque
chose pour y diriger même si
effectivement l'expression travail moi
j'espère vraiment qu'ils vont
m'apprendre à écrire parce que j'ai
besoin de ça donc je vais aussi attendre
beaucoup d'eux sur joe price et des
dynamiques
moi je suis pas un super bowl créé
auteurs j'ai du mal à écrire donc
peut-être que dans cette dynamique là il
va se passer des choses donc c'est ça
qui me fait place avec ça va être des
allers retours voilà je fais office de
vétéran mais c'est amusant d'avoir six
ce ce rapport générationnel et
intergénérationnelle quelque chose
quelqu'un auquel je suis attaché
donc ouais je vais peut-être pu
rapporter des thèmes que j'envie ou de
savoir ce que je défends moi les valeurs
que je défends et bien peut-être qu'ils
vont dire mais moi je les défends pas
pareil il y avait aussi et toutes ces
discussions autour des deux de ces
thèmes qui va être intéressante et ce en
ce qui concerne l'encadrement ce qu'il
faut pas oublier c'est qu'en fait on
vient on sent on vient de trappes et de
marmites fm aussi et on a nouradine and
que vous connaissez bien sûr et qui est
journaliste c'est à dire qu'en fait on a
déjà au coeur de notre action il ya déjà
cet adn là et notre idée un peu comme ce
qui s'est fait sur le bondy blog c'est
vraiment d'élargir le plus possible
c'est d'ouvrir des horizons et notamment
grâce à l'apport de journalistes de tv
fils j'espère sur ce média proche de
trappes est peut-être plus largement
après grâce à cet apport de journalistes
offrir quelque chose de nouveau
aux jeunes et donc est ce que voilà dont
las le projet commençait à peine votre
objectif c'est juste pas dans un an ou
déjà d'avoir plus de blogueurs de faire
combien d'articles par semaine ou par
mois
l'idée en fait comme on a là le site à
disposition ce serait ce serait très
bien de publier un article par jour
simplement pour ça faut créer un groupe
de blogueurs et blogueuses d'une
trentaine et d'une quarantaine de jeunes
et donc si dans un an on a ce groupe
relativement stable est suffisamment
motivé pour alimenter le site tous les
jours ce sera parfait ici on veut
devenir un blogueur autre api bloc
concret eh ben on va sur le site du
travail l'ogre à ew.com neuf.fr c'est ça
et donc vous verrez c'est assez simple à
voir sur la gauche il ya un onglet
contact et sur sept à partir de cet
onglet contact vous pouvez envoyer votre
message
en dix ans qui vous êtes ce que vous
voulez faire pourquoi ça vous intéresse
en 3-4 league et en laissant vos
coordonnées et bien merci beaucoup
monsieur dave nonis notre plateau de
vous avoir parlé du traspy blog mobile
entre happy blog ou suivra c'est une
actualité avec grand intérêt et
halloween accrocha grand approche à
grands pas pardon c'est loïc c'est ce
week-end avant les confiseries et les
déguisements
c'est bien la citrouille qui est
l'élément incontournable de cette fête
horrifique aline de loisirs les
apprentis sorciers confectionnent leurs
propres lantern sani bourdillon et
camille lambert sont allé récolter
quelques sortilèges regardez ici pas
besoin de baguette magique mais d'un bon
couteau à la ferme pédagogique de l'île
des loisirs ces ateliers citrouille
aujourd'hui une quinzaine d'enfants
s'applique à sculpter leur propre
lanternes
moi j'aime bien que les enfants puissent
décider eux-mêmes ce qu'ils ont envie de
faire un peu quand même qu'ils essaient
d esprit ludique
donc du coup les enfants vont dessiner
sur la citrouille tout ce qu'ils veulent
enlever et du coup on va plutôt confier
les parents les aux parents les couteau
et l'a ensuite on va découper dessinée
creuser et découpé réaliser sa lanterne
un travail plus physique n'y paraît
après l'effort le réconfort
la chaire de la citrouille est récupérée
pour une soupe maison une manière aussi
de faire aimer les légumes aux enfants
ça leur fait découvrir les graines qui
peuvent replantés après
la chair qui vont manger ensuite
certains enfants n'aiment pas la soupe
de citrouille mais là d'un seul coup ils
vont l'aimer
donc c'est tout bénéfice et puis c'est
cory jane salle attitrée elle l est
c'était une fille et elle a des désirs
en forme de triangle et les bouches et
ceux réussis
j'ai creusé avec eux un couteau et j'ai
dessiné d un peu d or s'il est des
polonais voilà une fois la lanterne
terminé il ne reste plus qu à l'éclairer
et maintenant nous allons en direction
de la verrière si vous êtes gourmand le
reportage qui va suivre va certainement
vous mettre l'eau à la bouche je n'en
doute pas un atelier pâtisserie était
organisée ce mercredi dans la maison de
quartier du bois de l'étang nickel elle
me d'euros et patrick jacques de dixmude
sont allés derrière les fourneaux en
cueillir quelques conseils
cours de cuisine ce mercredi après midi
à la verrière la maison de quartier du
bois de l'étang organise un atelier
pâtisserie les pâtes feuilletées les
rouleaux et les confitures sont de
sortie pour réaliser des chaussons aux
pommes et à la framboise s'inscrit en
fait dans une programmation
en mensuel en fait puisque tous les
mercredis après midi on propose des
ateliers parents enfants ou grands
parents
petits enfants voilà c'est un espace
voilà qui permet de passer du temps avec
son enfant de partager une activité
voilà c'est ça l'objectif une dizaine de
participants petits et grands originaire
de la verrière et des environs se sont
inscrits pour mettre la main à la pâte
on a raison de l'impasse apprend lavable
à qui n'a pas ou là après comme adaptés
pour chaque c'est une très bonne idée
je pense surtout pour les enfants pour
leur apprendre
s'ils sont pas souvent avec nous dans la
cuisine et quand il ya des petits
moments comme ça c'est super après vingt
minutes de cuisson l'atelier c'est
évidemment terminée par une dégustation
en voyant le sourire des participants
comprend que la mission de ses
pâtissiers en herbe est accomplie et
qu'il n'a jamais rêvé savoir faire des
tours de magie pour épater sa famille ou
encore ses amis à l'occasion des
vacances de la toussaint une douzaine
d'enfants guillon pour toi ont eu la
chance de se prendre pour des merlin
l'enchanteur en herbe avec un vrai
magicien
retour sur l'un de leurs ateliers avec
la magic mélanie côté l'as de carreau
une fois la magistrate est toujours
facile d'être un bon magicien depuis le
début de la semaine mathias et ses amis
s'entraîne durement pour connaître des
tours qui pourrait impressionner leurs
parents et tout ça sous l'oeil d'un
magicien professionnel en bon magicien
c'est surtout beaucoup de psychologie le
relationnel joue énormément on est
beaucoup dans le dans le dialogue dans
les changes
il ya des règles aussi il ya des codes
ceux qui sont à respecter donc on essaye
notamment aux enfants de bien leur
inculquer ces règles règle numéro qu est
toujours resté fin toujours se taire et
ne pas dire les secrets avant qu'il soit
fait et pour que ce secret ne soit pas
découvert ces apprentis magiciens lui en
courtois âgés de 8 à 12 ans répète
régulièrement il faut s'entraîner
plusieurs fois pour pouvoir le réussir
on fait des tours et on part on fait
disparaître des choses ont fait voyager
des pièces et s'échanger des cartes dans
des paquets des choses comme ça et
souvent les gens sont assez
impressionnants demain ils recevront
leur diplôme de magicien prouvant leur
talent et si vous pensiez que nous vous
révélions le petit truc qui rend le tour
magique
nous n'en avons pas le droit foi de
règle numéro 4 et comme chaque jeudi
vous n'avez maintenant l'habitude c'est
l'heure de la chronique sport avec
michael mineo ronsard michael bon surf
lohan alors du rugby pour débuter cette
chronique sport je sais que vous adorez
le rugby et oui on peut rien vous cacher
je suis fan du travail de france hédi
ben arous avait pas de hédi ben arous
week-end mais d'excellents joueurs chez
les seniors plaisir plaisir reçoit ce
dimanche à 15h wade ma maison pour le
compte de la 4e journée de fédérale 3
pour l'instant tout va bien pour plaisir
je vous le rappelle florane plaisir
descend de fédérale 2 l'équivalent de la
4e division en rugby pour nous parler de
cet événement nous recevons sur ce
plateau le coach le nouveau coach de
plaisir jean miss bonsoir bonsoir
alors ce début de saison est idéal en
trois victoires en trois matches on peut
pas fermer
oui mais difficilement
voilà c'est vrai qu'un bus avec deux
victoires à l'extérieur une à dunker que
l'autre à caen
c'est vrai qu'on fait une bonne début de
saison après il faut pas mettre faut pas
s'enflammer non plus la saison est
longue il ne fait que commencer et déjà
on déplorait aussi quelques blessés donc
faire attention
et est ce que ce derby on peut appeler
ça un derby contre rueil malmaison est
important pour la suite de la saison
on va dire que tous les matches sont
importants puisque on les prend tous les
aînés ailleurs les autres maires rueil
malmaison je les connais pas ce que
j'avais dans la poule qu'on ait un club
aux poteaux combo la saison dernière
donc je vous connais déjà l'équipe je
sais que c'est une équipe très
accrocheuse et très joueuse qui
ressemble un petit peu d'ailleurs au jeu
que vous pratiquez le club de plaisir et
vous pensez qu'on peut vous poser les
problèmes c'est l'équipe devra oui bien
sûr bien sûr sinon ce serait déjà
prestigieux de notre part de les
dénigrer
et en plus ce ne serait pas juste le
groupe a beaucoup changé depuis à la
saison dernière non non non non non il
n'a pas beaucoup changé
j'ai un pronostic je peux être path of
non faut pas dire ça faut pas dire ça je
pense que on verra déjà la fin de la
saison
si ça marche ou pas mais c'est vrai que
le groupe l'ossature est resté donc ça
c'est déjà bien parce que souvent quand
un club descend on a toujours tendance à
malheureusement déplorer quelques
départs là c'est pas trop trop le cas
unique un ou deux je crois dont un plus
c'est une mutation professionnelle donc
voilà mais par quoi tu ya eu quelques
arrivées très intéressante à des postes
où peut-être le club pêcher la saison
dernière c'est à dire quel poste par
exemple à l'ouverture
on a eu l'apport d'un ouvreur de métier
entre guillemets au centre aussi
quelques joueurs qui vont amener et
tirer le groupe vers le rouge pas de ça
et vous pensez que c'est peut-être ces
postes clés peut-être qu'ils ont fait
défaut à plaisir une dernière
alors je n'étais pas au club de plaisir
l'année dernière mais forcément un poste
comme le demi d'ouverture est un poste
clé au rugby ça c'est certain que le
mannequin manqué d'un bon joueur à ce
poste là ça peut effectivement dommage
et le club et cette année vous viser
clairement la montée nous pouvons pas
vous cacher bah forcément forcément
puisque le club descend de fédérale 2
donc forcément l'objectif premier est de
remonter la remontée immédiate
surtout que le club a très bien figuré
lan dernier et que c'est juste sur la
dernière journée où ils se sont
malheureusement inclinés qu'il soit dès
samedi
est ce que les joueurs sont justement
revanchard par rapport à la saison
dernière et ce qu'ils ont envie cette
année de remonter tout de suite
ah oui mais moi je la dass voilà jada
soit quelques regrets quoi en disant ok
on était bien c'était bien la fédérale 2
il faut qu'on y revenir tourner lyon en
8e oui donc là là pour ça oui la
motivation riez et pas de souci merci à
vous d'être passé sur ce plateau je le
rappelle le match entre plaisir et web
maison est programmée ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade robert barran on reste
dans le rugby on jouera également chez
les bélascain les moins de 21 ans ce
week-end les futures hédi ben arous au
seront peut-être à versailles ce
week-end à match est programmé dans la
catégorie des bélascain au stade de
porchefontaine rencontre opposera ce
dimanche à 15 heures le rugby-club de
versailles l'entente plessis meudon à
ces bébés et sèvres à noter que
versailles la seule équipe du
département avoir une équipe de moins de
21 ans
j'ai eu l'occasion de les voir et je
peux vous dire florane que le jeu va
vite et c'est très spectaculaire
et pour finir on referme cette chronique
sport par un rendez-vous en football le
chine et 3e du championnat excellence
reçoit au stade michaud maurepas dernier
du classement avec un match en moins la
rencontre paraît déséquilibrée sur le
papier mais mort paille capable de
réaliser un exploit à tout moment on l'a
vu sur la vie après sa victoire contre
torcy en coupe de france la rencontre
est programmée ce dimanche à 15 heures
voilà foraine vous connaissez tous les
rendez vous sportifs du week-end dans le
département
alors merci michael on vous retrouve si
je ne trompe pas dans quelques instants
pour votre nouveau talk si on parlait
sport dit comment les thèmes qui seront
abordés alors jean le chroniqueur sont
évidemment les starting blocks nous
allons parler notamment du la
qualification de versailles pour les 7e
tour de la coupe de france et du skipper
versailles et tanguy de lamotte qui a
pris le départ de la transat jacques
vabre j'espère vous allez suivre
l'émission est bien bien sûr je ne le
rateraient pour rien au monde michael et
intel
une dernière question est-ce que c'est
déjà la toile il ya trois semaines
environ trois semaines
est-ce que vous avez vu les ours non je
ne veux pas vu les ours est bas alors et
punchy il se paie cash et écouter cette
information ça va peut-être vous
intéressez juste avant de refermer ce
journal un petit mot de la météo l'hiver
sera rude et sont les ours du zoo de
thoiry qui nous prédisent leur
comportement donne de sérieux indices
quant à la précocité de la saison froide
et à sa possible rigueur ainsi la météo
mais tu es météo touahri ours annonce
que nous allons avoir un hiver aux
températures très basses
l'année dernière seulement 20% des 17
ans barry bal du château et du parc de
thoiry avait hiberner et ils préparent
ils préparé exactement leur leur terrier
mais cet automne il sonde ils ont tous
commencé à creuser leur terrier ceux qui
n'innovent vraiment un hiver très très
froid
alors si vous souhaitez aller les voir
dépêchez vous car le zoo de thoiry ferme
ses portes le 11 novembre
après il sera trop tard pour voir les
petits oursons c'est la fin de cette
édition je le rappelle à 19h30 on
retrouve l'amitié la niederau entouré de
ses chroniqueurs pour le talk sion par
les sports demain un nouvelle édition du
7 8 le journal présenté par wilfrid est
riche il recevra jean frédéric poisson
député des yvelines et président du
parti chrétien démocrate
pour ma part je vous retrouve lundi à 18
heures pour une nouvelle édition du
journal en direct je vous souhaite donc
un bon week-end et une très bonne soirée